Adoge, I can't believe we're meeting here, baby. It's been a
while since I've been so healthy. I'm fine. Now that I think about it, how was
Christmas? Did you go to church
? No, I didn't go. I didn't go to church. The same people weren't Christians, were they? No, they were
in America.  My family is Catholic, but
since I went to college, I've stopped going to church.I
guess I'm American.I
have a strong impression that everyone goes to church.Well,
when I was little, I used to say
that.  So,
what do you do in the church?
Basically, you listen to materials, pray, etc.
Then you drink wine.  It's true, isn't it? It's so
strange. No, you see,
all Japanese people are non-religious, so I
can't imagine it. Oh, I see.
Yes, it's true. When you enter a shrine, you go
first.  If you don't wash your hands, that's what happened. Yeah, be
careful. Then next
time, no, it's the same one. It's not 22 claps. I'm sorry. I always
forget. No, I'm
Catholic. Oh, I really do
drink wine in church.  That's right, I guess it's
a bit strange if you ask me why the wine isn't too random.Then I guess I'll just have some
amazake and go home.